>> ALL RIGHT.
LET ME JUST SAY NO ONE SOMEBODY
DANCING ON THE GRAVE OF SOMEONE
WHO JUST LOST HIS JOB.
IT IS TERRIBLE.
BEFORE LAUGHING AT BRIAN
TONIGHT, NO JOB IS SAFE,
EVERYONE IS REPLACEABLE,
EVERYONE MAKES MISTAKES, EVEN
ME.
>> BRIAN FOR CNN, LET ME ASK
BRIAN STELTER.
I'M FEELING NOT  -- NOSTALGIC.
WHO WAS THIS MAN I SPOT ON THE
TRAIN?
IT WAS BRIAN.
HE TWEETED I'LL ADMIT HAVING
SORE FEET IF LAURA ADMITS TAKING
CREEP SHOTS.
FOR THE RECORD I DID NOT TAKE
THAT SHOT BUT SOMEONE ON THE
TRAIN DID AND THEY FORWARDED IT
TO ME.
THANKS FOR BEING A GOOD SPORT
BRIAN.
FOR THE SAKE OF SOCIAL ORDER,
EVEN WITH THESE CUTE ORANGE
SOCKS OF YOURS KEEP YOUR SHOES
ON IN PUBLIC.
>> NO BARE FEET ON